o micrón dispara los casos de kobe 19 en
américa la organización panamericana de
la salud dijo que esta variante ha
provocado que los contagios en el
continente se hayan duplicado durante la
última semana chocante si comparamos con
el año pasado durante la semana que
terminó el 8 de enero de 2021 las
américas reportaron un total de 24
millones de casos mientras que este año
para la misma fecha hubo 6 millones de
casos reportados un aumento del 250 por
ciento ohl metros ya detectado en 35
países y territorios de américa por lo
que está en camino a convertirse en una
variante dominante en el continente el
panorama es el siguiente
eeuu registra el mayor número de casos
nuevos y a principios de enero reportó
un récord de más de un millón en un solo
día sólo durante la última semana méxico
tuvo su cifra más alta desde el inicio
de la pandemia y sobrepasó los 300.000
muertos pero reportó el mayor recuento
semanal con más de 70.000 contagios en
argentina y paraguay los casos positivos
han aumentado casi un 300% otros países
que han experimentado un incremento de
casos son colombia ecuador brasil y
bolivia la ope s pidió no categor como
una simple gripa aunque produzca
síntomas parecidos mientras que la o ms
dijo que no se le debe subestimar su
capacidad de causar daño spiegler
seamos claros si bien omicron causa una
enfermedad menos grave que te está sigue
siendo un virus peligroso
particularmente para aquellos que no
están vacunados casi 50.000 muertes a la
semana siguen siendo muchas aprender a
vivir con este virus no significa que
podemos o debamos aceptar que ese número
de muertes según la oms en más de 90
países aún no han vacunado al 40 por
ciento de sus habitantes y en áfrica por
ejemplo el 85% de las personas no han
recibido una sola dosis el organismo
mencionó que es difícil predecir si las
siguientes variantes causarán un tipo de
enfermedad menos o más grave